bom dia a todos obrigado pelo convite a
fazer parte desse evento é eu parei
alguns slides 12 vai disparar a apenas
orientar e isto a nossa conversa eu vou
direto segundo slides e depois se for
necessário volta o primeiro site
então qualquer ideia aqui a idéia é
mostrar que o centro de gravidade da
nossa sociedade tem mudado ao longo dos
anos
ou seja hoje em dia o que nós temos é a
o como grande patrimônio do da
humanidade o conhecimento é vamos
lembrar o que já teve uma mega sena
universal teve uma vez na mega sena
universal foi feito um sorteio e sorteio
saiu para espanha e portugal e o prêmio
que ganharam o goiás américas e todo o
ouro e toda prata que estava debaixo da
terra acumularam riquezas que nenhum
país tinha e há 40 50 anos atrás de
espanha em portugal teve que ser
resgatado da miséria pela união européia
então aquilo que está debaixo da terra o
ouro ea prata que você acumula ao longo
dos anos foram dando lugar a um outro
tesouro quer o tesouro que estava em
cima da terra o que é o ser humano e
aquilo que ele foi projetado para fazer
o que é criar inovar e produzir
conhecimento então nós temos hoje um
dilema qual nível de conhecimento nós
queremos desenvolver o que nós queremos
ser nós queremos ter conhecimento
somente necessário para operar coisas
que outros produzem um bom pegar como
exemplo uma máquina tecnológica que é um
carro de fórmula 1 me permitam usar a
este exemplo então nós tivemos o melhor
operador de carro de fórmula 1 do mundo
a 800 enquanto ele meu
nós fazemos parte do jogo quando ele
morreu
nós saímos do jogo ou queremos ir um
pouco além
além de operar coisas que outros fazem
será que a gente quer ter um
conhecimento a mais
hunter coisas que outros fazem manter um
carro de fórmula 1 ter conhecimento para
isso técnicos para isso
ou queremos ver um pouco mais e ter
capacidade e conhecimento no país para
montar um carro de fórmula 1
ou queremos ir além
teremos capacidade para fabricar
componentes de um carro de formula o
projeto feito por outros mas porém
capacidade para fabricar componentes no
país
ou queremos conhecimento um pouco mais
além e terá capacidade de fazer
engenharia e projetar um carro de
fórmula 1 brasileiro com a marca
nacional ou queremos virar lei
não só produzir um carro de fórmula 1
mas sim ter capacidade de inovar criar
novos conceitos suspensão ativa um novo
design uma nova aerodinâmica ou queremos
ir além e tem capacidade de produzir
ciência novos materiais novas formas de
mobilidade
então nós temos que decidir o que nós
queremos como país em termos de
conhecimento
vamos querer ficar na indústria 2.0 onde
o que se valoriza o lucro e cada vez
mais as empresas competem por lucro
nós temos digamos dois sistemas que
disputavam o lucro ao lucro é do
empreendedor não o lucro do empregado
nunca do empreendedor não luca do
empregado
aí vem alguém desempatou esse jogo e
falou o seguinte vai sobreviver um
sistema que melhor permite a criação de
inovações sinal de renovação não terá
lucro para dividir com a inovação você
consegue sair da disputa do lucro e
estruturar organizações que geram valor
gerar valor é muito mais do que dar
lucro
você pode gerar lucro porém destruindo a
natureza não somar você destrói valor
você pode gerar lucro porém usando mão
de obra ficar
você vai produzindo vai destruir valor
o que nós queremos
montar um sistema que produza que cria
valor e criar valor também é criar lucro
por ele usa ele utiliza de outras
dimensões também ok
bom cada ator é responsável por um
desses níveis de conhecimento
normalmente
aqui nós temos para montar para fabricar
fábricas e indústrias de engenharia
inovação nós temos grandes corporações e
institutos de pesquisa
o departamento de pesquisa e ciência
normalmente nós temos a universidade não
podemos confundir os papéis
não podemos confundir os papéis cada um
tem um papel importante
devemos lembrar que grandes inovações
acontecer em ambientes que estão fora da
universidade
não podemos depositar essa fatura
somente nas universidades para produzir
inovação promover a indústria morrer
comia as corporações devem também fazer
parte desse esforço de produzir inovação
só gente olhar as grandes invenções a
luz elétrica motor transistor circuito
integrado linguagem programação sistemas
operacionais nasceram em ambientes que
não eram ambientes universitários da
universidade ela tem um papel para
formar pessoas e todos em ciência não tá
aqui pra produzir é dispositivos da
indústria
então a alma um vácuo no país nesse
setor aqui porque nós não dispomos de
grandes corporações com marcas nacionais
nós já tivemos algumas experiências
interessantes quando o brasil decidiu
entrar no na produção de veículos de
carro nos anos 50 qual foi a decisão
tomada na época vão produzir uma marca
nacional
o famoso montar a decisão foi montar
montadoras
toda a engenharia a ciência que estava
por trás aquilo era um feito nas
matrizes no mesmo momento na mesma época
coreia decidiu pela sua marca investiu
aqui em cima do gol depois poder chegar
aqui e hoje é uma marca global porque o
modelo atual modelo atual valoriza
não está debaixo da terra aquilo que
está em cima da terra o que é
inteligência humana
o ser humano não foi feito para ser
burro de carga
para isso foi projetado burro o ser
humano foi desenhado projetado para usar
a inteligência para produzir inovação
criatividade
então a aal grande a grande sacada está
em valorizar e desenvolver essa essa
parte por outro lado a gente sabe fazer
quando o brasil decidiu fazer avião qual
for a decisão vamos contar a peça de
avião e montar no brasil não foi nos
anos 50
vamos fazer avião começou se pela
criação do ita
depois você tem a fazer pesquisa
desenvolveu se um piloto de um avião e
depois 20 anos depois nasceu em breve
então nós sabemos fazer não é que a
gente não sabe a gente sabe fazer
então a grande sacada está em investir
no conhecimento para que a gente saia do
mar vermelho da briga de lucro o próximo
ano azul que a geração de valor e aí a
gente volta pra um grande tema de volta
aqui
o tom é como nós transformamos o nosso
potencial e a gente escuta isso há
muitos anos o brasil tem um potencial
como é que transformamos nosso potencial
em potência e como transformamos essa
potência energia ea analogia não poderia
ser mais imediata do que a analogia com
uma hidroelétrica por exemplo né
nós temos um potencial que um rio
caudaloso e uma queda mas é só um
potência 1 não foi construída uma usina
uma barragem
você não transformar esse potencial em
potência
agora se você não consegue transmitir
essa potência energia não pode
distribuir mover as fábricas iluminar as
casas né você não entrega essa
a mesma coisa nós poderíamos fazer com
um país
há quanto tempo a gente não escuta que
nós somos temos um grande potencial e
esse desenho aqui não deixa mentir
é uma verdade olha esse desenho aqui
mesmo que você não esteja enxergando o
detalhe mas dá pra entender a filosofia
de desenho aqui nós temos três círculos
que denotam países que têm grande
extensão territorial países que têm
população um grande número e países que
têm pib riqueza tem quatro países ali no
meio para dizer a verdade três que têm
território tem população em pipe brasil
china estados unidos o quarto país que
está ali no meio é a rússia que não tem
uma população expressiva menos 150
milhões e milhões mas eu coloquei ali
porque tem 20 mil bombas atômicas
eu não quero encrenca com o russo então
ele está ali no meio junto com o grupo
toque mas a rigor a rigor brasil china e
rússia então nós temos um grande
potencial e olha que estamos falando não
é de qualquer território não tem um
metro quadrado de deserto um subsolo
maravilhoso 12% da água doce do planeta
um solo espetacular em salvar a pátria
o que falta a gente dá um salto
o que falta pra gente sair das condições
que estamos pra poder galgar aquela
escada do conhecimento e entrar num
mundo de geração de valor e sair do
mundo de pura geração de lucro e dejetos
[Música]
só tem uma solução só tem uma estrutura
que tem que ser construída para poder
explorar esse potencial
a educação não tem outro elemento
qualquer outro elemento ele não tem vida
longa
a única coisa que têm vida longa
investir na educação e no seu entorno
que é a ciência a inovação ea pesquisa
enquanto não apostarmos uma educação
universal plena absoluta justa perfeita
que alcance todo mundo
nós não iremos construir a nação dos
nossos sonhos
perguntado uma vez eu não lembro o nome
da pessoa
perguntado como é que se transforma
pessoas em inovadores e inspiradores e
empreendedores a pessoa respondeu não se
transforma assim como não se transforma
então não tem jeito como é que faz então
jogo cuide para que nasçam olha aqui
resposta
cuide para que nasçam um de uma escola
de uma boa alimentação de uma boa
assistência à saúde
dei as bases que ela vai crescer
criadora inovadora e vai fazer a mudança
que a gente tanto espera então a
educação e não uma educação simples
limitada e restrita mas universal de
qualidade já que a que alcance cada
cidadão cada criança desse país é tendo
isso daqui nós podemos pensar em fazer a
mudança no ambiente diz que a gente
disponha de três elementos um ambiente
econômico em um ambiente político o
ambiente social onde essa educação vai
fazer a diferença onde a inovação ea
criatividade não gosta de ambientes onde
não existe liberdade de expressão
ela foge disso
foge onde não há liberdade de expressão
não vai acontecer e inovação
criatividade não vai ficar lá na
indústria do lucro distribuindo miséria
ok então um ambiente onde é valorizado o
pensamento crítico e onde é estimulado a
criatividade onde a escola é um centro
de gravidade da sociedade não tem outra
saída
ela não pode ir na periferia tem que
estar no centro de gravidade na
sociedade
não sei então é fundamental que eu tenha
um ambiente onde esse potencial
transformado pela educação possa fazer a
mudança em que a gente tanto deseja onde
todos façam parte desse sistema onde
todos façam parte desse ambiente bom e
um último recado que eu desço a educação
o como elemento fundamental do país
mas ele só vai ser um elemento
fundamental do país só se ele foi
fundamental pra você aí a pergunta que
eu faço é a educação é prioridade pra
você você coloca toda a sua energia na
educação você coloca os meus melhores
minutos na educação você coloca os
melhores pensamentos tenham na educação
você investe tudo que você pode não ter
o conhecimento quando a resposta for sim
você quando a resposta for sim pra
família onde a propriedade da família
educação
quando a resposta for sim para a
comunidade
quando o foco principal da comunidade ea
educação
aí sim ela vai ser prioridade para nós a
do contrário não vai acontecer a mudança
que a gente imagina
a escola tem que sair da periferia e vir
para o centro de gravidade na nossa
sociedade quando ela vier para o centro
quando ela foi o prédio mais bonito
quando ela for a estrutura mais admirada
quando ela ter o respeito da comunidade
aí sim nós estamos iniciando o ciclo de
mudança o que a gente tanto espera
era isso que eu queria falar pra vocês
muito obrigado
i